Model view octopus is everywhere, but most people don't call it an octopus.
They have much more boring names for it.
Sorry, Larry.
MVC stands for a Model View Controller.
MVVM stands for Model View ViewModel, that's one word at the end, ViewModel.
Model view presenter is MVP.
You might run into all three of these in your professional career,
but don't panic like I did when I first learned.
They are all just different ways of solving the same problem.
How do we separate concerns so we can minimize connections?
So, with MVC, our octopus is called the controller.
With MVVM, we call it the view model.
And MVP, we call it the presenter.
Now, if you Google these terms, you'll find tons of articles and forum threads
discussing all the differences between these three different paradigms.
But those articles usually assume that the reader knows that they're
fundamentally at their core the same thing.
They're [SOUND] all octopi,
just with slightly different personalities and preferences.